I don't even know why we go to me stupid  for you there's one ham you guys how  many our kids are going to play together  [Music]  like go I got a ponytail right now hello  hey if you like your Bachelorette  weekend stop running  we are people protest okay mommy's me  has been amazing I really do yeah we're  not your court go go get out of here I  call the remix digit you're gonna have  to share with Tippa uh who dad by my  Australian friends messed robot oh my  god yeah bashing them ready to just  active down here and I'm ready to attack  this weekend's all about us just like  old times  what's next but really fast  how are you I know that things are crazy  right now what you're going to have a  lot of material for my wedding future  I had this nightmare where we had all  killed a guy no what no oh my god jet  lag is insane you guys it's no joke no  joke  you  you